[Music]
move over Hans cuz there's a new villain
in town and his name is um okay so we
don't exactly know who the new villain
is but we do have some super convincing
theories to share with you keep watching
to find out who's really responsible for
the magical pink fire we see in the
frozen two trailers didn't your parents
ever warn you about strangers there's no
denying it
Elsa is a stand-up girl she's sweet
nurturing and everything a kingdom could
one in a queen but else is also a super
powerful Disney Princess who can change
the season as easily as she can change
the TV station believe it or not but
there are plenty of clues that point
towards also being the villain in frozen
- however we're pretty sure that she's
none the wiser it's possible that her
powers are so strong that they have a
mind of their own
let's take a look at the clues her
starters granpabbie prophesied about
Elsa's abilities when her parents first
brought Anna in for treatment transp
Abbey says that Elsa's powers will only
grow he says that there is beauty in it
but also great danger as he says this
Elsa's magical essence turns from blue
to pink we see this blueish pink essence
come to life once more in the newest
frozen - trailer it appears as though
Elsa's powers are fighting each other
for controls just look at how the blue
and pink flames meshed together as they
burn through the enchanted lands but the
clues don't stop there we also see a
scene where Kristoff grabbed Zhanna by
the arm and quickly rides away on Spence
bag but if you look in the background
you'll see Elsa crouching down it's
almost as if Kristoff is trying to save
onna from her very own sister
this would make perfect sense if elsa is
struggling to control her abilities and
putting the people she loves in danger
another puzzling moment occurs at the
beginning of the new trailer also is
trying to freeze the ocean and feel
miserably she falls through the ice and
is coming up for air when a mean-looking
ice horse tries to stop her but when the
horse sees Elsa he disintegrates and
lets her pass it's very possible that
Elsa is responsible for the pink flame
but does that really make her a villain
if you think Elsa is the real villain
leave a snow flake emoji in the comments
section below focus here now let's check
out another very convincing theory
anna has suppressed powers many frozen
fans have wondered if anna harbors any
abilities of her own because well it
just doesn't seem fair that Elsa would
have powers and not honor their sisters
after all right fans have speculated
that Ana's abilities would be tailored
around the summer season so we're not
surprised to find out that fans are
pointing a finger at Anna when it comes
to the pink flames so here's our theory
now that anna knows that magic exists
her dormant powers are starting to act
out it's possible that anna has powers
of her own but when Grandpa V erases her
memories of magic he suppressed her
fiery powers on his abilities would have
eventually revealed themselves but her
clogged memory stopped them from
emanating instead she harnessed them
deep down until they could no longer be
quieted and now all these years later
they're starting to seep through there's
a clue that could support this theory
and it mainly shows itself in the first
frozen two trailer weather the pink
flames are on us doing or not there's
one thing we can't deny honest power is
love with this in mind we can't help but
think that the heart-shaped fire ring
and honest love go hand in hand now we
don't think that Anna wants to hurt Elsa
and Olaf over losing control of the
powers you didn't even know you had can
be pretty overwhelming if you think Anna
is responsible for the pink flames leave
a fire emoji in the comments section the
giant monsters and the trolls frozen
fans have long since suspected the
trolls of being tricksters since trolls
aren't exactly the nicest creatures when
it comes to Norse mythology Franz Xavier
and his crew are suspects when it comes
down to it we have no reason to believe
that the trolls are evil creatures
especially since they raise someone as
and gentle as kristov however they could
have ulterior motives
we then see Elsa looked startled as
large boulder like monsters appear
before her eyes these large monsters
have a similar body composition as the
mountain trolls so could they be linked
or working together
it's a popular theory that the trolls
are actually evil but we'd like to
believe that there is kind that they
pretend to be so let's explore another
theory what's the issue dear why are you
holding back from such a man the girl
from the trailer the mystery girl from
the trailer looks a lot like onna and
the blond haired boy looks a lot like
King Gagner so here's our theory the
unknown boy and girl that we see in the
trailer are actually L Santana's
ancestors and the Pearl has similar
powers to Elsa one day while venturing
through the enchanted lands the girl
accidentally struck the boy in the head
with her magic and he was sent to the
trolls for treatment this is the same
blonde man we see in King AG nars book
but what happened to the girl is it
possible that she was so afraid of her
powers that she ran away and built an
ice castle somewhere in the north this
could explain why King Agner flipped
past a picture of the snowy mountains
before landing on the page with the
troll and the first man on it could the
fiery villain actually be Elsa and Ana's
relative The Snow Queen another possible
theory is that Disney is using Hans
Christian Andersen's story The Snow
Queen as a reference if this is the case
The Snow Queen might be the one
responsible for the pink flames since
The Snow Queen has often been pictured
with white horses this might be white
disney has chosen to showcase them in
the sequel if the Snow Queen is the real
villain it would explain why our heroes
are going north to uncover the truth we
mean why else would there be an ice
castle at the top of the mountain Pete
so which one of these series is your
favorite let us know in the comments
section below to play and be sure to
tell us if you have any theories of your
own give this video a big thumbs up if
you love frozen and don't forget to
subscribe to the things for the latest
Disney news thanks for watching we'll
see you next time
[Music]